so so I'm going to begin by sort of like
going lab rating on something that Ryan
said yesterday so we're sort of looking
at the connections between sore lower
bounds and algorithms and particularly
the connections between proving lower
circuit lower bounds and and in d
randomization it's what I'm supposed to
be doing but I'm going to make a little
digression say like maybe when we look
about algorithms involving circuits we
can group them into two categories and
this is kind of implicit and what Ryan
was talking about yesterday so saying
the circuit analysis category you're
given a circuit see and you want to know
what can you say about the function the
circuit computes and we can talk about
inverse circuit analysis in inverse
circuit analysis you're given a function
and you trying to say what can we say
about the circuits that compute that
function so one example that Ryan
mentioned yesterday what is the minimum
circus size problem given a truth table
for a function compute the size of the
minimums I circuit for F so that's one
example of inverse circuit analysis and
just as like we'd be happy with any kind
of sir you know any kind of circuit
analysis algorithms maybe we would be
happy with a much weaker inverse circuit
analysis algorithm you could think of
and I guess the thesis of Roseboro
andrew dish was at such an inverse
algorithm such an inverse circuit
analysis algorithm is implicit in most
of the loan on lower bounds okay so what
do we mean by that so so lets you know
here we're talking what is a kind of
generic inverse circuit analysis
problem okay so it's just a property of
the truth table of a boolean function
the boolean function might have or not
but it should have something to do with
the circuit complexity of that function
so so they gave three axioms or three
conditions that a property could have
and these these conditions actually they
have a lot of knobs on them that that
can be moved to fit a variety of
circumstance I'm just going to pick one
setting of the knobs so that its
polynomial time should know I'm
forgetting what their names were
constructive be constructive if give an
F we can tell
in paw in polynomial time whether F has
the property and one note I want to make
here is that polynomial time since the
input is the whole truth table for F is
really exponential time in the input
size to the function f ok so if F is a
boolean circuit on n input bits then
polynomial time is time to to the order
at ok then a second property that would
be nice to have is that it has something
to do with the circuit complexity of the
function and in particular is a way of
proving that the function is hard so if
PI of F holds this is called being
useful in here technically I'm saying
it's useful against polynomial size
circuits then if PI of F is true then
the circus complexity of F is at least a
super polynomial some super polynomial
function and again we can put in all
sorts of knobs say certain classes of
function of circuits here and certain
quantitative bounce that we may be more
demanding thank you and the last
condition is the one that we're going to
be sometimes using and sometimes not but
let's go with their traditional approach
to start with called largeness
is that it isn't true that almost you
know that almost nothing has this
property so the probability of a random
F that pie of a random function f is at
least is a most exponentially small in
the input size and this is this is this
was chosen because all their theorems
hold even if it's only the small I think
intuitively you would think that a
property that would that would come out
of a circular lower bound would hold for
almost all random functions not just
non-negligible fraction of such
functions but all the theorems that they
proved about these properties were also
true with just this week as we Clark
miss condition okay so any questions
about this definition so they did two
remarkable things the first thing is
they observed that if one-way functions
exist one-way functions yeah
I'd like the other person lying day at
work past the last possible so we can
test the property in Vernonia Tiger can
be depressed if the properties but
unless we remember is we can test in p
weather fiber yeah yeah okay
or i could say not maybe i was confusing
two things so you can either say pie
itself as NP which means that we can
test whether pie holds in poem in in
polynomial time okay so where f is given
as a truth table so this means to to the
order and time let me just say
oh yeah late with that
the length of the truth table for us oh
yeah this is yeah sorry is the
parenthetical remark so it needs another
okay so this is this the square now okay
so they showed that if cryptographic
one-way functions exist well then you
get cryptographic pseudo-random
generators then you get cryptographic
pseudo-random function generators and
what a pseudo-random function generator
is is a way of constructing easy to
compute functions that look like random
functions if it looks like a random
function it should edge you know this
largeness condition says none with
non-negligible probability it should
have the property some of them should
have the property but since they're easy
to compute all of them have small
circuit complexity and that can't
contradicts usefulness
so actually it's very likely you know
they have a very interesting notion of
natural property and it's very likely
though that their definition is the
empty set these properties don't exist
okay so okay but my facility is still a
very interesting notion but you know
because you can like play with the knobs
and say you know this may be true for
general circuits but for those kinds of
circuits that we have lower bounds for
there are such properties and the look
there implicit in the proofs the
properties are implicit in the proofs of
lower bounds
okay I'm going to leave this up although
maybe can I move it to the other side
let me try doing that see if it works
Wow okay so because we'll be referring
to the same complexity class classes
this time okay so um here's an so they
probably don't exist but we haven't
rolled it out cryptographic cryptography
might be impossible what's the what's
the connection with with the
randomization okay so let me just give
so remember so we've been looking at
probabilistic algorithms with
potentially two-sided error but another
class of algorithms that would be really
interesting to have our error-free
probabilistic algorithms right there
sometimes they don't run fast enough and
that's where the the choice of rendus
matters but when they give you an answer
it's a correct answer that class is
called zp okay and so this is a little
bit informal because about promise
problems and so on but there's something
that's that's not too too hard to show
although it uses the machinery of D
randomization if there is a natural
property
then the circuit approximation problem
that we've been talking about the one
that's hard for bpp would be in zero
error probabilistic time to to the end
to the epsilon or every epsilon okay and
here's why so remember the the diagram
that we had on in Tuesday's lecture or
maybe you don't remember so i'm going to
write it down again and that's we had a
generic way of taking a function f and
mapping it to a pseudo-random generator
G sub F and the harder F was the the
smaller the seeds for the pseudo-random
generator were and then we said any any
way of breaking a key to the f
distinguishing it from random gives us a
small circuit 44 f in the other
direction
so okay and we have to use the kind of
low end version of this for the way I've
stated it because the natural property
just guarantees that you have super
polynomial hardness not like exponential
hardness so that's just a note for
people who know these things otherwise
you can just ignore that okay so I mean
saw solving the D randomness
distinguishing problem with like fifty
five percent chance of success
so if you can tell the difference
between the the range of key and random
strings and guess which whether your we
are in the range from the range or from
a random string with more than say fifty
five percent chance of being correct
then you can use such an algorithm to
construct the circuit c sub f you can
use a say any circuit that does this
solves its distinguishing problem to
create the circuit c sub F okay so um so
here's how we're going to solve the the
CIP problem okay so we're going to sew
say that we want to estimate it's going
to be a number of circuits flying around
so let's say we're going to estimate
some circuit that I'm just going to call
d because it's the letter after see if
you already have some seeds here so we
want to estimate the probability over X
that D of X is 1 what we're going to do
is so they say this Sadie run you know
has it has T gates then we're going to
pick you know this we have a guarantee
of usefulness that's end to the Omega
one we're going to pick an N so that
this end to the Omega one function is
significantly bigger than T ok but that
means that means that n st grows is
going to be t to the little of one
okay so maybe I should have put a tea
here T is like the size of the input
when we make it clear okay so then we
pick
a random function on on n bits and we're
going to hope that it's a hard function
moreover we're going to hope that we
know why it's hard so we test whether I
of F holds and that's in time to to the
little n if it does we know that F is at
least this hard until we if so we
construct G sub F and run the of X for
every X in the range of G sub F
okay and you can see that you know the
seeds to Chiefs of FR about and n bits
long a little bit more so we have to
actually like but polynomial related to
to this end and the and so the time
taken by this algorithm we have to like
test whether this holds that's going to
be about 2 to the end time or polynomial
and 2 to the end time so 22 the order n
time constructing G sub F is also going
to take about 2 to the end time and
running d sub X the number of outputs of
of the pseudo-random generator is going
to be 2 to some polynomial in it so all
of this procedure takes time to to the
polynomial in N and n is little oh these
little T to the little o of 1 so the
total time this algorithm takes is tu
tutitu the little of one so that's the
time it's a probabilistic algorithm in
that we have to pick F but we want to
claim that whenever we produce an answer
so we might not produce an answer
because f might not have this property
in that way we just give up but there's
a non-negligible chance that has the
property from the largeness and if so
then then we're guaranteed that this
circuit d cannot solve the we know that
F has has if PI holds F has hardness
which means this thing doesn't exist
which means that there's no t-step
algorithm that breaks G sub F in which
case when we run d sub X on all of the
range of G will get a close to the right
answer
so moving my hands a bit but but
hopefully the ideas is somewhat clear so
you use as the machinery that we talked
about we didn't really do on Tuesdays
any questions about this okay well we
said that these properties don't exist
probably because if we believe in
cryptography they don't exist what kind
of weak it you know so if we want
something that might also you know some
other related property that might have
both you utility in circuit complexity
and in the randomization what might we
drop well of these conditions to
tweaking it to give it more of a chance
of existing well at least you know to
have it be an inverse analysis algorithm
we want it to be an algorithm and we
want it to be relatively efficient so I
don't think we want to enjoy change
constructive attiki how about usefulness
well if we drop usefulness all together
it'll be useless thank you so we won't
be able to conclude anything about
things having the property how about
largeness
well seems like you know intuitively a
random function should be the hardest so
largeness makes sense as far as like a
heuristic about our our proofs but at
least it's conceivable it makes sent it
would also make sense to have a useful
constructive property where largeness
didn't exist up to a point what is that
point
we wanted not to be empty because like
the empty property still is not very
good for us okay so so let me go and say
like not it's no longer natural but so
we need our new new notion so I'm going
to call it on Ozzy natural
if we replace see
with I'm going to need that again non
emptiness so just saying that this
probability is greater than zero I that
there always exists such a function yes
what about relaxing usefulness to sort
of work like approximate usefulness or
so what would it mean you want to be
useful yeah so we can look to find
usefulness against like smaller classes
of circuits that's still interesting we
could define it as you like usefulness
and again we could increase the dosage
of usefulness maybe to say there's no
circuit that approximates it but that
actually makes it stronger then maybe
like no semi uniform if you had a
probabilistic notion of useless like
almost surely is it yeah that's the no
property is almost surely useful that's
true yeah or you know i'm going to say
nothing no property the opposite of the
null property the just accept everything
right so we know most functions are hard
so like heuristic useful we could just
say yes
okay so so I encourage people to look at
variance of this but I'm not going to
talk about all of them today I'm going
to talk about several variants of this
today but not every single possible one
okay so now this you know we've dropped
this actually the the cryptographic
impossibility no longer applies because
because you know you say okay well still
we can't tell we can't tell a
pseudo-random function from a random
function but a random function almost
certainly doesn't have the property
possibly and the pseudo-random function
might not have the property might never
have the property no contradiction okay
so
okay so
let's think about what what kind of
properties are p constructive in this
sense in non empty and then just like
think about whether what it would mean
for them to be useful so let's like keep
condition a and C for a while just think
about this in the abstract see where
such properties land in this kind of
hierarchy and then like say now what it
would mean what would it mean for them
to be also useful okay so so a property
of a truth table you know the truth
table for function is just a string of
length 2 to the N okay you can think of
it just as strings of a certain length
okay it's not exactly a power of 2 you
can round up or round down interpret it
as you as you as you see so just like a
property that's not empty and
constructive just means that for every n
there exists some F so that um I of F is
true okay so um
so we're going to have like a total
functions in NP interest group so for
people in the who will be in the total
functions in NP interest group you can
think of this is exactly total functions
in non-traumatic exponential time
because here sort of the search problem
that always as possible is to find a nap
so the PI of F okay and just like so TF
NPR search problems for NP problems that
are always pumped but always have a
solution search problems that always
have a solution
and here the input is n so in
exponential time we can evaluate whether
whether F is a possible solution okay
and so TF NP is just a little is between
TF NP is a little bit between NP + reset
Cohen P and NP and it's much closer than
P intersect colon P than it is tempe in
some formal sense okay or informal sense
maybe not a formal sense in my thinking
is what I think of it as much closer to
NP terzetto NP so so the class that
we're defining is in between NX vendors
to cohen x + NX and is is a
sandwich in between these two but I
think of it as much closer to the bottom
than it is to the top so any questions
about this okay but since it's very
related to enter centerset Cohen ax me
and you know maybe we can think about oh
okay so let me actually say back up a
minute and see so another here's another
way of thinking about these type of
problems so we'll go back and look at
natural natural properties as well with
the largeness condition they're also
interesting in this in this way what
this means is that you have some kind of
object and you have a kind of guarantee
or proof that that object always exists
something with though so you have like a
property and you're guaranteed that's
something with that property always
exists just that's just restating okay
and you have some way of verifying that
property okay so we have lots of
problems where you know we want to
construct something that has a certain
property and we have some non
constructive proof that there is
something with that property so I take
an expander graph it's easy to see that
a random graph is an expander graph but
it's relatively hard to actually come up
with a constructive expander graph okay
so um so
the end so you know you think of the
natural properties the one that have a
non-negligible chance those are the
properties that you can prove something
exists by the probabilistic method
without any subtleties you know like I'm
using lavash local Emma okay maybe now
it's even with the local Emma if you
have the constructive proof okay so um
you see something with the overwhelming
probability so anyway so so lots of
things we can so anything where we have
this kind of constructive argument you
know sorry probabilistic argument but
not a constructive argument that's
that's unnatural property in some sense
or so we say that's a property with P
constructive attea enlarged pneus and
then when is it natural when is it
useful it's when there's no actual
simple construction to be had if there's
a simple construction that's going to
that simple construction is going to be
a small circuit that determined that
describes the object in question most of
the time yeah that's a good notion of
what a constructive construction of the
object is is a small circuit that
implicitly describes you the the object
is a rule that says 12 vertices have an
edge between them for example in the
case of it expanders so um so the
existence of a natural property would
say here's something I know things exist
by the probabilistic method but there is
no way of constructing them period not
that I don't know how to construct them
there's no simple construction period
so that's natural property if we drop
largeness it's just that instead of we
just drop the condition there's
something that we know how to construct
we know exists by the probabilistic
method we just crossed out by the
probabilistic method here's some kind of
class of objects that we know how to
that we know exists but there is no
simple construction and so so like so
the question is is so we think is any
property I in TF any useful saying is is
there any is equivalent to saying is
there an inherently non-constructive
existence proof and I guess technically
you know to be an existence proof I not
only it's not only that pie isn't EFMP
that we're actually able to prove that
pie isn't TF NP in some system but um we
if it's true but not provable we could
always adopt it as an axiom ok so this
clear says kind of subtle point so this
is this is actually where we started
thinking about easy witness at least two
two of us I don't know if Valentin was
thinking this way okay so um okay so
okay where's the connection to two
circuit complexity and where's the you
know the summer I can push a connection
to circle park city because we're
talking about things are useful for
circuit complexity but where's the
connection to like proving particular
functions to have large circuits and
what's the connection to D randomization
i'm going to give you like the the easy
directions and then the easy witness is
is like generalizing in a way that makes
it much harder but also more useful so
let's just take this argument and say
well what if there is a quazy natural
property what do we have to change from
is so what what word do we have to
eliminate in the description of the
algorithm random because a random ones
not going to have the property now okay
so how can we pick something how can we
pick something non randomly hey when
when they're just few solutions so we
have to change the model of computation
so instead of picking it randomly how
can we pick it
non deterministically pick non
deterministically function f on n bits
and the rest of the algorithm stays the
same and but then the can because we're
changing the model the conclusion
becomes different we have to change one
letter in the statement which letter the
that disappears and it gets replaced by
and actually i guess said p disappears
and time okay otherwise it's exactly the
same argument so um so there there's the
connection with D randomization we don't
know that bpp is in non deterministic
time and this would this would say that
some non-trivial non-deterministic the
randomization of BBB as possible if such
things exist now do we believe that such
things exist we didn't believe that
actual natural properties exist but I
say there's actually a good reason to
believe that these clausing natural
properties exist let me give you a
reason to believe you said TF any is
just a little bit above an X finish that
connects for any intersect colony so
here's what I'm going to clean its claim
it and then the proof is just going to
be like one line so um if any intersect
colony is not contained in peach / poly
then there are fuzzy natural properties
and
and I'm going to try to switch the
boards around though they don't go that
that way okay so i think i'll have to
erase I think this board has actually
served its purpose now so we can erase
this diagram
whenever I say that I'll need it the
next thing okay so the proof is ok we
need to construct a property so what is
the problem in annex a problem in MX
means that for every incentive like that
you know something's in NX finish echo
in X means that if something is in the
language L so you know liddell be in any
intersec aunty L not in p / poly and
here's how we're going to get the
property okay so I mean there's like an
exponentially long witness w sub X that
X is an l and you can verify that
witness in polynomial time in the length
of the witness so in exponential time in
X means polynomial time in the length of
the witness but if X is not NL since
it's also in co any if X is don t know
there there's a witness w prime of x
that that x is in the compliment and it
has the same kind of properties so here
is going to be the the property k pi is
going to be FF it's going to be true if
f has the following form it's a you know
a list of all 2 to the N X's and free to
either
a witness that axe is in the language or
a witness that X is not in the language
okay and say like the bit this is so
that we can know well we're talking
about on the bit is X in the language
okay so why is this constructive well
remember the is constructive in the
input size the emphasize is 2 to the N
times 2 to the order n okay and what we
have to do is in that amount of time go
through and verify each of these
witnesses see which way is supposed to
be and then verify that there is a
witness for that direction so it's it's
polynomial time in the input size which
is huge why is it a non-empty well when
this is always exists there may be
multiple witnesses it might not be
uniquely defined but it's always non
empty in the final condition is it
should be large why should it be large
say we had a small circuit lowers the
contradiction a small circuit would be
computing the witnesses for every X each
bit of the witnesses but would also be
computing these piece of X's which just
tells you whether X is in the language
so you just restrict the circuit to just
give the beasts of X and ignore the rest
of the part and that would be a small
circuit 40 so if we had a small
description of this whole mess we need
in particular have a small description
of the truth table of F of L which we're
and we're assuming L is not in p / poly
I should probably say it's not like L is
not infinitely often p / public bump I'm
going to brush that kind of detail under
the rug here in many ways I promised
Valentin that i would start lying at
some point
and I might as well start now okay so so
square so that's actually kind of a you
know i think is quite likely that NX
gender psycho index is not in Pete /
poly doesn't you know everything not
just an exponential time but a
non-deterministic exponential time in a
sec OH non-deterministic exponential
time isn't have a polynomial size
circuit so I believe that these
properties really exist okay but just in
case they don't exist this is not the
this is sort of an analog of the easy
win this lemma for an expander said
Cohen X just in case they don't exist
I'm going to like look at even further
winking weakening and it just says
why don't you have a name
maybe barely natural it's the best name
for it it's not really that close to to
being natural just says going to drop
that it's always non empty and replace
it with occasionally non empty and
actually an alpha drop always useful and
say occasionally useful though the one
thing you can say is it has been amply
often useful and non empty at the same
time so you can't alternate here it's
empty so it's useful here you know I
guess that every time is empty its tip
by default useful but I only want to
count the ones that are not empty to
infinitely many of those are actually
useful okay so okay so we said that sort
of like the you know this relates NX
banner said Cohen acts to whether
there's a quazy natural property what's
the what's the corresponding thing for
barely natural properties and so this is
the I'm actually able to like state the
theorem that I'm supposed to be talking
about now
easy witness is that barely natural and
this is actually like a version due to
Ryan but early natural properties exists
if and only if Andy is not containing
well you proved that it's equivalent
yeah this just like to move the property
around this yep otherwise i have to give
some more definitions okay so let me try
to give the sketch of how we prove it
and unfortunately it's a little less
direct than the version for an ax bin or
psycho in X so but not is not so bad and
it just uses one of these shelf
collapsed arguments just a little bit
convoluted one okay so um
uh
so in let's assume so I think the hard
implication is to say say that we've got
okay i guess maybe i'll do the easy
implication first so say that barely
natural properties don't exist
okay then what that's saying is really
okay it's 11 observation is we can sort
of like get four in any language we can
give every input its own length so so
what this means is that whenever we have
a relation between X and w fw exists and
here w is exponentially long but
verifiable in exponential time which
means polynomial timing the size of W if
W exists there exists as a small circuit
so that C computes w so C at input I is
the ice bit of W implicitly represents
the circuit okay so that's like saying
this is the property is it a witness for
X and it's not useful so therefore there
is a if there is a witness there is a
succinctly describable one and the size
of C is into the order one so instead of
searching for W if we want to solve this
problem instead of searching for W we
search for C so and then in exponential
time verifies producing on overall its
inputs is producing the bits of the
witness so what have you assumed in
order to say that you've assumed so this
is so we're saying barely barely natural
properties don't exist the property of
being a witness is constructive and
we're assuming it exists so so it's not
empty
so if it is constructive and not empty
and we don't get a useful property we
don't get a barely natural property then
it's not useful so that means that there
is a way of writing it as a circuit and
so we searched for see instead of W so
we run in exponential time to to the end
to the order one rather than in in w
exponential time so on this shows that
any is contained in exponential time
here and this is like a yeah so if if
these don't exist any is contained in
exponential time and then the other
thing that you can see is that also
exponential time in this case is a
contained in p / poly why because if not
the truth table for an exponential time
problem just like we did with any inner
circle any if not the truth table for
that exponential time problem is itself
a natural property
not in P slash poly is itself a quazy
natural property that's very similar to
the dilemma about an x-intercept context
but I'm running out time some night or I
already ran out of time so I'm not going
to actually give the details so in so
together saying any is contained an
exponentially so any is contained in p /
file it's just what we want to proof
okay the other direction is is is more
roundabout but um
if we use the same kind of construction
with this barely natural property we
just have to like change a little bit
so first thing is saying like assume
there's a barely natural property
so then if we use the same construction
but just sometimes it messes up
completely what we because we're trying
to look for a function that in a set
that doesn't exist that's empty what we
still get is that see a peepee is in
infinitely often non non terminal sub X
okay with a bit of advice which I'm just
going to ignore I couldn't bring myself
to completely lie but by building I'm
going to lie but I'm going to tell you
where that I'm like so you basically get
a similar result containment of CA p and
you say like when it works it only works
sometimes but when it works it gives you
a d randomization in art or music sub
exponential time okay and then the next
thing that will we see is that well now
when do the Shelf collapse either X biz
in p / poly or not just like we always
do if X business so if X is not in p /
poly certainly non-traumatic X is not in
p / poly and we're done so the the thing
we have to worry about is that X might
be and p / poly but now if X is in p /
poly we already saw that then x equals
Merlin Arthur time and since cap is in
nondeterministic
sub exponential time this is in
combining the non traversing move in the
probabilistic check with just the
tourism this is in non-traumatic sub X
in here i am i ok because it's a little
more complicated but now x visit
non-deterministic sub X and that means
that something strictly stronger than x
is in non-traumatic expert when you
scale that up ok so when we scale this
up we see that say time 2 to the n to
the Omega 1 for some Omega 1 function is
in is contained in not true mystic
exponential time but looking at the
Kanaan argument said ok in in this
amount of time we can directly diagonal
eyes and get something not with with
large circuits so this we can say
directly by the Kanaan argument is not
in p / poly so something that's not in p
/ poly is contained in on x IE and act
is not in peace / poly
and I lied at a variety of points so but
that's the idea not expose oh I see Pat
nem nuong X right you don't care the
difference and so Marco Yeltsin get a
chance to ask his technical question
because I glide too much ok so so that
is sort of like says that in some sense
you know some variety you know Roz were
uprooted said it heuristic alee natural
properties are are what we use to prove
circuit lower bounds and this is saying
in some sense some variety of natural
property is necessary and sufficient to
prove circuit lower bounds exactly what
we use and note that this is the
statement of this does not involve
randomized algorithms at all but
improving it we ended up using even like
the you know d randomization you know
all the constructions of pseudo-random
generators from from heart functions
were implicit in the in this cap in in
this step beyond where we put cap in
okay so so that's another kind of
example of the strands of spaghetti
merging and getting stuck together
saying the if you're a we said before if
you're interested in uniform models you
still have to understand circuits and
now we're saying if you just want to be
proves to circuit complexity you have to
understand randomness or at least it
seems like it's coming out of nowhere
and up hearing
so okay and then I think ryan and his
talk is actually going to be using this
at some point I hope the next dog okay
okay okay so-so oh I did want to like
some you know leave with an open problem
the open problem said okay you know like
to understand this whole mess we had to
go all the way up to non-domestic
exponential time and this question of
whether there's a barely natural
property is is a question about whether
search problems at nadra mystic
exponential time are kind of simpler
than search problems at the NP level
okay can sit you know when NP you
wouldn't expect the witness for an NP
problem to have any particular structure
or be describable a small circuit they
can be arbitrary but for any what kind
of what is any anyway so any you can
think of as your favorite NP problem
translated for a special class of
instances that have succinct
descriptions and in 11 such classes you
know you like do the logical version
where the succinct description is some
kind of in circuit that implicitly
represents the input and we're comparing
it against circuits that implicitly
represent the witness but you can be
very much more concrete if you in in in
your notion of succinct description okay
so one a lot of NP complete problems are
say if you look at like one tape turing
machines as your machine model you can
see that a lot of the np-hard problems
like independence that are so on are any
hard on on graphs with the following
credit when you're given the following
kind of implicit description you have
like a very small graph
and then some kind of graph product and
GN the the grid n by n grid okay and
this is really like the number of time
steps your algorithm takes and this
represents the finite control of your
Turing machine okay so this you know
solving your favorite your favorite NP
complete problem on graphs with this
kind of simple description is uh is any
complete and hear what I mean is H is
given explicitly and then G sub n is
just given by you the number n ok and
that's what it makes it any because you
have to actually to write down the graph
it itself is is exponential time so on
so the general kind of question
is what can we say about either the
exact or fixed parameter complexities
of such succinctly describable
instant this
it's very big problem I will not give an
explicit dollar amount because it's so
vague but just in general refer
submissions to the committee
case-by-case basis so but is the the the
kind of idea queer to a couple people
okay that's it
he presented an integral is that the
research yes yeah then then we get even
a natural property because then the
minimum circuit sighs problem becomes
polynomial time
you know because you know minimums okay
I should have said minimum size circuit
property is sort of the ideal natural
property because it is useful at all
levels and only if you can keep the
computer only if you can actually
compute it only if you can put in a pit
yes if you could put it in p it would be
the ideal natural property so I guess
what I mean that's a good you know
suggest a question of you I mean we what
we like things in p how much do you have
to inhale first one if you kept some of
the other things right so they talk
about quality polynomial time and it
have many of the same consequences and
again it would be a trade-off between
how strong you had as a pseudo-random
generator how how what kind of size
bound you wanted to be useful for which
ones are possible which right so there's
the the three can be traded off
quantitatively so I seem to recall some
some work mentioning not a true you know
like NP varriya sofa so yeah steven has
a a kind of strange paper called like
hemi bits semi bits demi bits and mping
super bits and any natural proofs and
you have to yeah like this I am not
qualified to talk about that paper and
not even qualified to say the name
you